ce qui vous préoccupe aujourd'hui et
vous en attendez beaucoup ce sont les
résultats de ce rapport cette enquête de
l'igpn dont vous n'avez pas de site pour
l'instant vous attendait beaucoup de sa
wii écouter ça fait presque un an et
demi que le capitaine du gipn a été
envoyé par le ministre intérieur la cuc
la conclusion enquête a été conclu fin
mars dernier et nous avons essayé
d'avoir des deux de trois nouvelles
concernant cette enquête et jusqu'à ce
jour c'est le c'est le silence complet
par rapport à un autre combat on a eu
beaucoup de soutien énorme déjà par le
par la rotation des femmes battues dont
madame céline l'oliveraie et madame anne
cécile mifare la président de
l'association qui nous soutient elle
nous adresser tout ça tous ces mots de
d'encouragement pour pour continuer dans
notre combat le 6 juillet dernier elles
ont établi un assemblement pour le
soutien des fans qui s'est déroulé à
paris
suite à cet astre blement elles ont été
accueillies par le distincts térieur
pour élaborer tout ce qu'ils puissent se
produire pour apporter des choses
nouveau pour éviter qu'un qu'il ya des
femmes qui skient piste ce beau rire
dans des conséquences atroce et elle
roule états ont obtenu un entretien avec
le ministre intérieur
en fait ce qu'il en est sorti cet
entretien quelqu'un est sortie elles ont
essayé d'aider d'expliquer cas par cas
il ya tellement de familles en
souffrance qui vivent dans des
circonstances atroces
est ce qu'elles ont essayé d'apporter
des grenelles si vous voulez vous aussi
vous savez apporter des choses
supplémentaires
quand il ya des plaintes sont ordonnés
quand quand il ya des pratiques un suivi
très attentif et suite à leur entretien
elles ont demandé concernant notre
dossier à savoir que le ministre
intérieur était très très mal à l'aise
il a noté sur papier son insistance a
dit oui c'est la faire avec aurélien
valet qui a fait un coup de botte dans
le doubs et puis city lui ont dit que
tic qui est allé faire au maximum pour
apporter cette conclusion donc vous
attendez ça ça serait une avancée très
importante pour vous d'avoir six
conclusion exactement ce que ce qu'on
veut c'est qu'on puisse savoir que la
justice soit juste parce que ça fait six
années que nous sommes là c'est de la
passion c'est les longues allées dur et
puis on voudrait c'est pas en finir en
voudrait que cette justice assure juste
l'état a reconnu qu'un dysfonctionnement
ya eu cette enquête nous avons les
preuves et les éléments qui prouvent les
dysfonctionnements concernant un
policier et un gendarme
c'est pas une vengeance c'est qu'on veut
qu'elle sait être puni ce que c'est
normal en tant que citoyen français
vous faites un une santé car vous êtes
amendable et pourquoi que des gens qui
sont payés tout par l'état qui sont
protégés j'insiste là dessus j'insiste
moi avec mon fils giovanni pin autre
avocat on ira jusqu'au bout
comme quoi tient en soit on est soutenus
alors
le fait d'être soutenus par ces
associations qui se battent pour le sort
des femmes est-ce que ça fait partie de
votre réparation de ce que vous attendez
est ce que le relais de cette parole là
vous soulage aussi parce que vous n'êtes
plus seuls c'est pas facile au départ
quand on a enclenché cette enquête qu'en
mode coop
quand notre avocat qui m'a pris dans les
bras en me disant patrie qui a été très
grave on va faire tu
on va faire tout en sortent ensemble
avec votre office et jusqu'à ce jour
après tout quand il ya eu ce giovanni
qu'a ouvert hommage à une princesse sur
un lien nous avons reçu des messages du
monde entier
c'est un soutien énorme c'est pas comme
c'était une joie c'est qu'on n'est pas
seul et pis ça montre l'exemple aussi
parce que vous savez il ya énormément de
familles qu'ils aimeraient avoir
cette vérité ces différentes anneaux
mais une vérité par rapport à leur
combat par rapport à leurs souffrances
et on veut apporter vaincre est ce là ce
courage cette force pourrait à la maison
à attendre autant conduire des choses en
face dignement